what's up everyone welcome back to
simulation at the Women in Technology
summit we are saying now Josh Mane's now
hey you good thanks for coming on the
show hey thanks for having me it's great
to be here yeah yeah it's greatly great
to be here with so many women that are
building the future and that aren't so
inspirational and you yourself are also
very inspirational so let's sit down and
talk about what you've went through who
you are and where what you're building
into the world so darker Souls you got
it yeah so tell us a bit of a darker
Souls and how it came to be in your past
as well give us a little bit of a
backstory and where you are now yeah so
basically everything that I do now
revolves around the the field of
psychological trauma and helping people
overcome adversity Rhian TSA's you know
it's so it's still very stigmatized
field traumas widely misunderstood and
oversimplified and my goal is to help
people uncover the truth behind trauma
right to help them look at their
experiences through a completely
different lens to integrate them into
their lives and then become stronger
because of it so yeah that journey
started really about ten years ago when
I was shot and killed by an enemy sniper
in Baghdad I was serving in the in the
military and I actually the bullet
actually severed my femoral artery and I
died for fifteen minutes before being
revived and the journey afterwards
everything since then has has kind of
led to the work that's being done now
and it's considered a privilege to do it
where does one even start with that well
first is thank you thank you no thank
you
he's very service and holy crap getting
sniped Wow
what I just can't even understand what
that Phoenix like you know
the so here's that here's the thing well
one there's there's a lot of strange
things that happen that day all right
the to put this into perspective right
the the typical standard where where a a
physician would typically call it on a
patient in flatlines
yeah is around the six minute mark and
something prompted that medical team to
continue working on me for 15 straight
minutes right they administered over 30
units of blood we were at a very rogue
care facility minimal equipment I mean
the defibrillator paddles that they used
to shock me back to life literally came
into the base of that morning and they
had to use take him out of the plastic
to use him mommy and bottom line is if I
woke up at all they expected
catastrophic brain damage woke up with
no trace of brain damage full
recollection of the events you know up
until the point I took my very last
breath and was fortunate to make a full
recovery
so the only way that I can describe the
experience of dying right in there and
there was kind of a progression because
from the point I was shot to the point I
took my last breath was about 30 minutes
or so and you know there's a lot of very
bizarre physiological symptoms that
occurred yeah you know over that 30
minutes but but I think the most
important part is in in those final
final moments right when you're dying of
blood last year essentially suffocating
right and the body will attempt to pull
the remaining blood it has into the
chest cavity all right to protect the
vital organs and I could literally feel
this happening right so that the blood
would creep out of my extremities and as
all the believe they'd cramp up and
become numb and then that blood creeping
since you move up through my thighs and
they became numb and and when it when
that feeling hit my stomach it was the
first point where I realized the injury
was getting out of control
yeah and it you know it felt like I was
running wind sprints around a track
couldn't stop top right it was like an
anaerobic pain and emotionally
you know life didn't flash before my
eyes
like we sometimes hear about but I do
believe that what was most important to
me was revealed in those final moments
and just instinctively I started to
repeat three names in my mind over and
over again for the last minute of my
life and that was my mom and my two
sisters but when I feeling hit my chest
I consciously knew that was it took my
last breaths and died whoa whoa and the
you know question we get a lot is you
know did you see the white light did you
have like an out-of-body experience and
the answer that is no not in the way we
might traditionally think about it but
but what I did experience I think was
maybe even more profound because I know
I was still conscious for it and and and
what I'm referring to here is literally
the the precise point in time from the
transition from life to death like as I
was taking the last breath and the only
way that I can describe that feeling is
is one of absolute surrendered to
something much greater than ourselves
right and you through that surrender was
just an overwhelming sense of peace yeah
feels like the spirit becomes part of
everything and nothing at the same time
so total peak experience right there and
most people don't get to feel that twice
and a lot of time they don't you know
that the so this is interesting you know
when we look at at you know what we call
peaks peak experiences right certainly a
near-death thing can invoke that certain
psychedelic experiences can invoke this
you know rites of passage traumatic
experiences certain dreams right can be
profound enough to kind of dislodge us
from our past construction open the door
to new level of awareness right and with
what was interesting about this is is
one that happened to me ten years ago I
didn't know what to do with it right and
so
time's the biggest challenges we have
with adverse experiences or trauma is if
we're unable to derive meaning in them
and if we're unable to integrate the
experience into our lives in the present
moment it's almost like we're trying to
fit what's happening now into the model
of the past right and sometimes those
things don't line up and it can cause a
lot of adversity and confusion and into
our lives so that's partially what I do
is it you know help people look at their
experiences through a slightly different
lens and you know give them permission
to integrate it in a different way on
dark crystals calm which we have in the
bio you write from trauma to
transformation right and before we get
into that we have to stay here on the
story a little bit longer because it's
just nuts and it's important to unpack
so as this bullet lands through your
feet for neural artery and the blood is
slowly leaving the extremities and parts
of the body are becoming numb and then
you were noticing I'm losing too much
blood because it's now starting to creep
up into my lower body and to appear
towards like your guide then that moment
came of thinking about mom and two
sisters and repeating their names and
those moments with them that that that
that feeling crept in and that's kind of
like the feeling of of the people that
might have been most important to you in
your life and then the last sort of
breath and then and then that was a
feeling of just not being there anymore
and then waking up after the medical
team that operated on you yeah I
described that final moment as as you
know a feeling of absolute pure
awareness right
some of you know regardless of what your
you know spirituality or religious faith
is you know some may refer to it as like
feeling the presence of God right or
pure absolute awareness you know it was
a gift to experience that I what I find
is that it took 10 years to almost come
full circle with that experience and and
found that the the challenge the beauty
of that journey was to learn how to
revisit that moment and do it
consciously right and instead of being
forced into it and and that that really
requires like a surrendering right to
too much well you know what is surrender
I I like it surrender is not being
attached to the outcome right it's a
community to fiercely pursue that which
were passionate about but do we have the
strength to respond and and when the
outcome is not as we intended it to be
or expected it to be right there were
riding this wave of life we're going
through this journey but 10 years ago I
didn't I didn't have that perspective
right and woke up about two days later
after this injury in the Green Zone to
learn that I died for that long
for two days I have about two days and
then you know I was I was evacuated back
to the United States to recover and you
know it's fortunate I snap back from
this injury pretty quick physically at
least and was back in Baghdad four
months later about four and a half
months later he went back and I
volunteered to go back and now it's you
are truly nuts well there's you know
that there's this this
when you're part of a team especially
being in a leadership role right knowing
that my team was still in a great deal
of danger yes you know everybody we're
serving I mean not just the Americans
the Iraqis everybody we worked with you
know it's it's there's a profound sense
of guilt regardless of how irrational
that may sound right I hear what you're
saying
but there's a guillotine yep not in car
that main effort you know that effort
anymore yeah yeah yeah but this is this
is an important part of where kind of
these emotional seeds started to be
planted right because guilt and shame
are two of the most complex and
destructive emotions we have right and
then the figures up yeah yeah now
there's advantages to those right
there's reasons for all emotions across
the spectrum right but but when when the
levels of shame and guilt become toxic
you know that's when it can really turn
on ourselves and I that's what was
almost beginning to happen almost as
soon as this injury occurred right like
for example I look at guilt is almost a
form of cancer right that that in the
beginning it infects the deepest corners
of our soul you know and we're at stage
one yeah and we don't even know it's
there yet it starts to control our lives
in a way that in ways that we don't even
understand and as we continue to
suppress our past experiences and try to
ignore them and compartmentalize them
the more we continue to do that the more
it can take control of our lives
right and before we know we might be at
stage 4 and in crisis and not
understanding why you know as a specific
example of what I'm talking about and
the complexity of guilt you know I when
I was recovering the hospital I was I
was evacuated to a place called Walter
Reed Army Medical Center which is the
biggest Hospital in the military and
it's where all the most severely wounded
service members are evacuated to to
recover and you know medically
physically best care in the world but
there's nowhere else I would rather be
in that hospital but emotionally it's a
very difficult place to be you know
you're surrounded by the worst of the
worst injuries amputees burn victims
you're seeing the impact that that has
on their families and even you know as
bad as my injury was you know I was one
of the only ones in the hospital that
was expected to make a full recovery
right so you know one of the images that
I'll always remember is walking around a
corner seeing this beautiful young girl
in her early twenties pushing around her
new double amputee fiance in a
wheelchair and you know that's an image
that just riveted me mmm so the guilt
that I was starting to experience was a
guilt in my ability to heal when other
people couldn't right coupled with not
being downrange with the team and that
kind of propelled me to do this thing
like you know irrationally so it you
know I was pulling staples out of my leg
with a Leatherman you know I was
throwing out my medical records and and
you know lying to do whatever I needed
to do to get back to that team you know
and there's there's a positive
resiliency aspect to that there was a
lot of positives but there's a much more
destructive side that wouldn't begin to
surface in soil years later right the
photo imprinted in my mind of what that
Medical Center looks like with all of
the people that have sacrificed their
health and well-being for I'm serving
the country and that's crazy
it's crazy and I think I think a lot of
people listening would like to you know
voice their discomfort with the amount
of war that the United States gets
involved in and sacrifices people in
that sense but at the same time it's
really important to remember that the
United States makes decisions like that
to remain a geopolitical leader and it's
very difficult to find that balance yeah
and and then also just that image you
know of you know the woman in their
young 20s with the man that had both his
legs imitated like that's that's crazy
it's crazy it's crazy
with family members as well and that
moment for you of well let's get to the
transfer trauma to transformation but
how exactly it went for you and how now
you're helping others just this like
moment of to me I to me I bet and this
is a bet but I bet that what you felt
when you went into death was somewhat
similar to what we experienced when we
go really deep into Eagle law so
psychedelics or when we go when we go
really deep into meditation for you know
a Weiner more at a time straight um that
there's just some really profound things
that happen to the of consciousness when
it dies right and I think that that that
area very much so interests me I think
you can provide a lot more equanimity a
lot more collaboration across the planet
a lot more love humanity and do you
think that that's right in that same
ballpark ish no III do yeah you know
there's it's interesting to see all the
research that's starting to come out on
psychedelics today manok and I actually
study consciousness I'm in a master's
program in San Francisco right now
taking a look at a lot of these things
and you know the layperson like the peak
experiences you know regardless of how
they're derived can have similar effects
on our ability to transcend to a new
higher level of consciousness right to
gain a drastically new perspective on
life as long as we're able to integrate
the experience of creation right and
that's that's where that's where the
challenges right it's a lot of a lot of
folks you know you know some folks can
run into the mistake of you know kind of
what's called spiritual materialism
where you're constantly chasing the next
spiritual high
of psychedelic use without integrating
the prior one yes right so so what's
interesting though is is is you know the
organization to kind of seem to do this
the right way or they almost trade it
ritualistically like that there's the
they respect the process there's an
approach there's there's you know a lot
of times therapy leading up to it so
kind of prep for the experience and then
there's a network of support surrounding
the person to help them integrate it
afterwards
yeah psychotherapy yeah exactly right
you know but it can be absolutely
profound yeah and there's a lot of
parallels like when you look at some of
the the similarities come out of like
dr. Rick Strassman to work on DMT you
know one of the common things that
people describe is this feeling of being
part of everything and nothing yes and
that is that is precisely what I felt
indescribable Issa right i part of
everything and part of nothing yeah and
I like people like it's it's it's hard
to conceptualize this right but because
it's not as if just the bad stuff falls
away right we're good and in the back
you fall into the sea of atoms yep and
you are no longer that what the brain is
doing and what you are inside of the you
are what you're perceiving through your
eyes it's it's the everything is a sea
of atoms and you become that and then
there's a feeling of nothingness as well
associated with that because then there
is no what you are the thing is the
consciousness and Ray nothingness is to
know consciousness right and and it is
it's it's very difficult to explain it's
much easier to experience and we don't
necessarily need extremely high doses of
psychedelics in order to to be able to
start getting to the edge the edge comes
actually quite quickly with psychedelics
you start getting to the edge more and
more slowly over time and like you said
integration psychotherapy are so crucial
ok let's let's unpack trauma with the
transformation so both for you and for
now facilitating others tell us about
this so
you know let me just share kind of what
happens right is if we took what
happened to me on the surface this idea
of getting shot dying coming back to
life going back to Baghdad four months
later right on the surface if we stop
there that would look at that would make
a pretty cool story right it looked kind
of like this mini hero's journey in some
ways it would yeah like you know it's
like archetypal warrior thing Lee right
yeah and what happened though is you
know 2009 the Department of Defense at
the time and I was still in the military
three years after this but they were
starting to become very serious about
psychological health you know suicide
rates are spiking you know depression if
I said the whole range of you know the
consequences of combat were starting to
service and and stigma was a huge
problem back then right and now today
I'll tell you that there's a stigma
around the word stigma right and we it's
it's very complex but rightfully so back
then the the main primary initial stigma
was was this fear of being branded as
weak and the fear of losing your career
you know if you sought help in the
battlefield yes
so as an officer as a leader like I was
able to get on stage entered into the
speaking circuit back then to reduce an
eliminate stigma right and oh yes so I
was on the speaking circuit less than
two years after this injury long before
I even started to understand what was
happening and what was interesting
though in the span of like two years I
did over two hundred talks like on top
of all the other jobs I was doing you
know CNN Fox Oprah BBC I was briefing at
the biggest behavioral health
conferences in the world I had an ear
clinical understanding of this topic of
post-traumatic stress and yet I still
failed to recognize the symptoms
the deeper symptoms yes in myself yeah
these yeah well that's that's where
that's where I found myself in the first
of many suicidal spirals to come and
here it is I'm just coming off of CNN
right and then suddenly standing in a
corner of the hotel I'm not having a
clue who I was in yeah yeah right gosh
and that's kind of like the Bourdain and
spade mmm a little bit it's like very
very highs and then how can I still and
call even Kanye West and stuff it's just
like you're so high and then in Kid Cudi
and all these just it's just nuts what
the climb up can do as you get off of a
very big high and then you get off that
high and you're just like what's the
question like you said earlier is you
can get stuck in wanting what's higher
and also not knowing yourself and going
into lows and and in lows can sometimes
hold people in the lows that you get
trapped in the lows this is a very
complex thing and you were able to
figure out only after you spoke you even
had a clinical understanding and this is
also very interesting if people can have
a like a clinical understanding of
trauma PTSD they have a clinical
understanding but the experiential
wisdom the feeling the energy how it
affects other people what those complex
interrelationships are within yourself
and others I heard it how did you end up
uncovering what the real raw this was
and that was a that first spiral was the
point where I realized that whatever I
was doing I was missing something that
was much deeper right and and what's
emerged it is you know again there's an
oversimplification of what trauma is and
and how we respond to it and many people
think or you know just because of
culture media kind of how it's been
portrayed is that post-traumatic stress
or what I call you know living in the
post trauma state how we respond to
adversity right there's kind of a
spectrum of what could happen how we
respond to that but but many people kind
of think that it's related to what we
call hyper
arousal symptoms you know it's anxiety
nightmares night sweats being jumpy at
loud noises kind of the proverbial
things that we hear about when when we
hear this term post-traumatic stress
disorder PTSD and those those types of
response are very valid right there and
they're true in the lives of many people
yeah but it's only one end of the
spectrum the other end of the spectrum
is called hypo arousal right and that's
much less discussed it's much less
because maybe it's harder to quantify in
some ways emotional withdrawal feeling
emotionally dead right being crippled by
the effects of shame and powerlessness
and betrayal and guilt these moral
ethical spiritual wounds right and and
one thing that we see a lot is our
inability to form loving relationships
with somebody else feeling emotionally
numb and dead and withdrawn and isolated
that isolation is deadly yes right and
and and that's unfortunately what will
you you know can see in so many
different places right in it because
it's it's hard to understand what guilt
is right what shame is what that
emotional void that we can experience at
that rock-bottom well I and by bringing
truth to what that is and and and
normalizing it for people validating it
for people the hope is that it can plant
plant the seed that might give that
spark of hope at the right moment to to
take that next step you know there's so
much power in the power of human
connection yeah and the relationships
that we share between one another yes
right you have to break the stone we
have to unpack it just a little bit more
before we move on hyper
what was the word hyper hyper arousal
arousal yeah
hyper or hypo yeah I ok so hyper arousal
and hypo arousal I haven't heard it
quantified this way before I I kind of
like it quantified in two different
areas because I think that's really
important it finally makes it a little
bit more clear kind of
what triggers people so hyper arousal
things like the trauma and then Haibo
arousal is things like seeing yourself
in a position that is that it's not
recognized by your community that I'm
not I don't have something that I love
that doesn't love me so that kind of
breakdown of those two things into
different areas is I wonder what
actually ends up affecting people the
most and there are the solutions
different for each probably what are the
solutions for each that are really
strong right now we see organizations
like maps multidisciplinary so see a
show for psychedelic studies yeah on
these three of clinical trials for MDMA
for PTSD so there's like this very
interesting solution or maybe the
solution for the high hypo arousal is
that we need a stronger social fabric
more love more community so yeah so that
was just very interesting you just
wanted it
yeah well and it gets you know our
experiences they're all relative right
and and there's often a mix of how we
respond in the post trauma State right
there's there's many different ways to
approach right that I mean that
depending on the person depending on the
situation you know that could range from
things like cognitive behavioral therapy
for long exposures therapy EMDR
neurological techniques right that
there's there's a lot of different
therapeutic modalities out there that
that can address different aspects of
this what I'm what I'm primarily focused
on was what I do is is bringing more
awareness to the the generality of the
topic right this does not one trauma
doesn't discriminate
Yeah right that's good eight it impacts
all of us from every walk of life right
and and and even though the the nature
of our experiences could be completely
different the emotions that manifest
from them can be very similar right and
minoo when we talk about the power of
human connection I some think that you
know well because it was in the military
the only people that could understand me
were military folks right or if I'm an
engineer the only people that could
understand we're engineers right and and
I found that the opposite to be true
right sometimes I found people who could
connect with me in places where I least
expected it from every background black
white men women gay straight engineers
social workers doctors attorneys right
the differences there were all people
right who had some point in their lives
in their own ways or exposed to the
darker side of human nature
the darker soul yeah the darker soul
they were they had the strength to be
vulnerable yeah right and that
vulnerability can bind us together the
very core of the human experience if we
allow it you know so here's the thing we
have the law we have to allow right it
takes these are very uncomfortable
conversations to bring up right this
this the what we experienced in the post
trauma State can leave us feeling
isolated and defective as human beings
right like we don't fit in if we cannot
feel emotion right if we feel so numb
right if I'm in a state of chronic abuse
you know spousal abuse child abuse
police officers on the street getting
exposed to chronic trauma for thirty
years career you know military but you
know there's a it doesn't discriminate
right but but when were when were
repeatedly exposed to these situations
vulnerability you know it can it can
really cause us to kind of learn out of
survival to shut down our emotions and
and when we when we kind of get back to
what we might consider a normal
situation you can feel like we don't fit
in right to the point of like deadly
levels of isolation yeah you know so the
key is to you know normalize those
of isolation validate them you know give
people permission to look at their pain
validate the source of their pain so
that they can win America lies have
normalized holding space for people to
just be with their feelings right and
normalize vulnerability mmm especially
from men yep and that's why we're here
as male allies at Liddy yeah here's the
thing right like in the past like I I
I'm strong believer that in in in the
post trauma State we it's important to
retain the humility that in some cases
the people who are close to us in our
lives may know more about us than we do
in the present moment there were many
times that I can look back on
retrospectively where people will pick
up on certain behaviors or certain kind
of warning signs and they bring them to
my attention and even though I was
completely unaware of it even though I
didn't even maybe necessarily agree I
retained the humility to at least listen
to taking what they were saying right so
that person had to have the courage to
approach and have that uncomfortable
conversation I had the courage to listen
right it was a two-way street and the
point is it allowed healing seeds to be
planted in the mind that when I did hit
that rock bottom spiral there's that
little thread of hope right that's the
thing suicide is a condition of
hopelessness you know and you know when
we when we can create hope in the lives
of people through conversations like
this you know that's what we hope you
know we'll continue to propagate this
whole effort yeah a feeling of
hopefulness a feeling of there's a
there's a good song that Kanye and Kid
Cudi just pushed out called a reborn I'm
so I'm so reborn
moving forward
moving forward keep movin full of it so
that that feeling of continuing to move
forward and also holding the space for
people to just be with those feelings
and just knowing that there is hope and
how can we create more hope hmm and not
hopelessness because that is what
triggers but there are we have good
friends within the circling Institute
and they hold space for people we've
we've been within their space quite a
bit and holding that space for people to
just be what they're feeling is this
extraordinary it's confidential it's
extraordinary
we're not coaching people we're just
being with their feelings yep and we're
paraphrasing we're actively was sitting
in paraphrasing and validating and they
feel like wow this person gets meaning
like that's and that's and that's great
that great feeling and then at some
point at some point you know it is also
beneficial to coach as well because then
the the feeling of of once you are
validated once your feelings are
validated that they're heard then the
ability to move forward from that to
something greater than to actualize past
those feelings to what keep moving
forward what is that the value the
utility that you want to bring to the
world for other people to to feel like
you are part of the community that you
are contributing and that they're
contributing to you and ever and whatnot
so yeah that's the beauty of a darker
soul that was that you know there's a
world-renowned psychiatrists and
Holocaust survivor named Viktor Frankl
who wrote a book called man's search for
meaning and and in that book he says
that without suffering and death human
life cannot be complete and that the
suffering we endure gives us ample
opportunity to drive greater meaning in
our lives
so suffering is the universal process as
isolated as it can make us feel right as
detached as it can make us feel it is a
universal phenomenon transformation is
up to each one of us right it's an
internal process but it's not a process
that we need to take alone so when we
can learn to derive meaning in our
experience when we can grow from them
transcend through them and then be able
to apply it to the lives of other people
right that is the beauty of walking
through the darkness right it's a you
know one of the most fascinating things
that I've been looking into recently
thanks to one of my professors brilliant
mathematical cosmologists named Brian
swim in San Francisco and hook us up
with these smart people grow yeah it's
amazing so Brian looks at the you know
he goes back to the very inception of
the universe right what he calls instead
of the Big Bang that primordial flaring
forced right in in in at which time that
even if we were able to observe it right
which we couldn't because we're all part
of it right even if we were able to
observe it in the beginning it wouldn't
even look like anything it would just be
the shimmering it's the first billion
years right and and mysteriously the the
something caused right something caused
these gases to form something caused
them to start to gravitate together
right and and what happens is as a star
is formed right and then initially it's
just gas it's being pulled together you
know hydrogen helium and as those gases
pull together the force of gravity
continues to push it closer and closer
and closer now what the gravity wants to
do is continue to push it so close
together that it implodes and if it
imploded there would be no star and
there would be no us right so we're all
part of that same system instead what
does the star do in order to survive
itself combusts right it literally
sacrifices parts of itself setting
itself on fire in order to fight back
the pressure of the gravity right and
the point here is that as we look
through the evolution of the cosmos
all right all the way up so it's a life
to the present day that it's a process
of suffering and self-sacrifice right
and pain and destruction to produce
things that are more beautiful more
grand more complex right so even when we
don't understand the nature of our
traumatic experiences the sense of
isolation that is inherent to it you
know sometimes sometimes not feel alone
all we need to do is look around us look
up connect with other people because the
process is everywhere this I interesting
that it can be related to the cosmos to
the formation of stars Hey that is very
interesting and it has made me slightly
reconsider what I was gonna say earlier
but I still want to say it to just hear
your thoughts about it I think that it's
very much so possible that suffering is
extremely valuable and universal and
like you said suffering Universal
transformation requires hope it requires
so many other because a community
requires tons of other things and then
we get through that with our
transformation the suffering but I am
not sold on suffering being Universal
I'm not sold on utopic civilizations
having suffering I think that it's quite
possible a couple millennia down the
line maybe even just a couple hundred
years down the line if we can figure out
how to work together once everyone's
basic needs are met if me having items
doesn't preclude you from having items
that we've really traveled the Stars
that we know how to do these things and
we're doing that quite well and that
nobody's killing each other and all this
kind of cool stuff I don't think
anyone's gonna suffer and whether maybe
digital conscious maybe you don't suffer
with digital consciousness either so I I
don't and I don't necessarily think that
one needs to suffer in order to feel
happy
nests and stuff like that so there's
it's complex that's difficult but that
would be my slight challenge to that
thought just to see what you have to say
believe it let's look at what trauma is
right what is something a traumatic
experience is a situation or event that
fundamentally disrupts the way we
believe the world should work right and
it's not always what it seems right it's
not in a big reason why I do the work
that I do today right is that as human
beings we have a natural tendency to
compare ourselves with other people
right and when it comes to psychological
trauma when we do that
like for instance saying and I've never
been through a near-death experience
like you have never been shot before you
know what I've been through isn't a big
deal right but when we do things like
that we tend to minimize our own
experiences right and it's it's it's
it's crucial to understand that that
trauma is not always what it seems for
me death was the distraction right it
was the big obvious shiny object that
everyone kind of pointed to right that I
did I automatically believed and started
to assume that there should be something
wrong with me because of that experience
that this void I was experiencing should
be related to what this big obvious
thing was on the surface when it took me
nearly a decade to give myself
permission to understand that that the
near-death experience was the least of
it all right frankly you know going back
to what we described at the beginning
you know with the exception of losing
one of my other soldiers that day that
experience was a very positive
experience in my life yeah yeah some of
the Maddock ones if one figures out how
to transform are actually the most
important ones right so I that that also
makes me you know step back a little bit
more from what I said because maybe the
huge bits of suffering are so
transformational that they're the most
some of the most meaningful and you
bring up a really good point right it's
because it's important to discuss this
the what was traumatic for me right far
more difficult to navigate was losing my
father
I was seven years old right like like
the death in someone's life we all live
we all die right and that that
disruptive experience that that is it
can be a form of trauma right
it was the totality of the deployment to
Baghdad it was divorce it was living
with Crohn's disease you know an
incurable immune disorder far more
difficult to go through that right that
then to get shot in from from my point
right
it was financial distress it was you
know the suggested being an entrepreneur
there are there are the point is you
don't need to be resurrected from the
dead to be in pain right and and that
you know kind of the the way that we
react or respond to a situation in the
present moment is based off of our
constructs that led up to it right our
past constructs you know our past
beliefs and when something disrupts that
fundamentally disrupts that you know
that's that's what there's the whole
situation into in states that we might
not be ready or capable of handling or
feel like we're not capable of handling
in the moment you know there again I
come back to the power of human
connection right like there's nothing
greater perhaps than that perspective
that we can gain from one another you
know so
you know like what you you know again
kind of going back to this the you know
there's there's a power you know Brian
going back to this my professor you know
there's just this amazing work and
highlighting some of the fundamental
powers of the cosmos it calls it right
that are kind of consistencies in the
line of physics right there that's under
well I don't know right one of those
powers is homeostasis right you know
it's like the hawk and the rabbit you
know there's this beautiful interplay
between the two even though it's a
predator prey kind of relationship right
that that exists within this this band
that creates Mannino it's amazing when
you look at the cosmic if the cosmos has
expanded any faster any faster than what
it did it would have expanded too fast
and never would have existed if it
expanded any slower right it would have
imploded and never existed right and
it's almost like the everything
everything in the cosmos runs this
razor's edge that mysteriously produces
all of the complexity and beauty and
pain and pleasure that we see today you
know so it's it's a it's amazing just to
reflect on the all of all of it I think
we got to a really crazy question right
there about transcending right yeah Wow
okay how about we do a couple thoughts
from you before we get to these last
couple questions which maybe give us
your thoughts on kind of like what's
going on with darker souls kind of like
what you're building what it what
exactly it is give us give us that sure
so I mean part of what I do I'm a
professional speaker at this place so I
travel around the world I speak to a
range of you know any practically any or
you know Navy SEALs high school kids
executives whatever it is and the
purpose of that is to help dislodge and
disrupt the way we think about our past
experiences right trauma leaves us stuck
in the past
so injecting that new perspective giving
people permission
- you know baby reflect on their own
lives in a slightly different way give
them the confidence to do that so that's
important that's going to continue on
the backside of that III also you know
work was you know pretty heavy in the
health care industry was in the
behavioral health community to provide
cultural context training to clinical
providers to help them better translate
the needs of the populations that
they're working with specifically right
now I'm focusing heavily on law
enforcement first responder and military
folks but you know there's a lot to come
you know and if you're in a pond dr.
Scholl's calm I push out you know very
short one-minute videos that are quite
disruptive right so you know in a very
positive way right that they're they're
designed to spark conversation yes right
and if we can spark conversations around
the dinner table if we can spark these
deeper thoughts within our you know our
friends our family our loved ones our
co-workers we should be the first ones
to have these great thoughts with right
yeah you know like we talked a lot about
shame and guilt tonight and it's it's
like they as devastating as they can be
right they do have a weakness and that
weakness starts with shining light on
them so we bring those things to the
forefront and we uncover the root cause
it's not going back in the closet right
it's not it's it can't so you know
that's that's where the power of these
conversations come from
we could get to a point where family
were the first people that you could go
and talk about all the shame and guilt
and and then family could just be with
you and your feelings and be open and
have a sense of community your friends
and stuff without taking advantage of it
so that that's that's gonna be good I
know that happens in a lot of families
today but also the opposite happens
where families aren't safe space neither
as friends then what do you do then
there's a resinous how about the beauty
of a darker soul your book that you
authored released in January I love a
lot this this last year so the links in
bio tell us about the thesis yes so the
beauty of a darker soul which we kind of
teased out the paradox of that and what
we mean by the title it was written for
you right it was it was written as a you
know I could have wrote a book just
about the near-death experience and kind
of that coolest story but but had no
desire to really do that right I wanted
to be able to find a way to leverage
that experience to somehow benefit the
lives of other people and you know one
it's it's not designed to be a military
book obviously there's some military
things in there that are used as a
vehicle to get to a larger concept right
but I will tell you're gonna see a very
different form of what combat today is a
very human side of it that I think you
know your listeners might find very
interesting
certainly the near-death experience is
captured in there and whatnot but the
second half of the book really goes into
the paradoxes of what I experienced
afterwards and and the you know the the
the biggest advice I'd give if you pick
up a copy this is look at it through
your own lens mm-hmm right that's how
it's designed unfortunately that's the
feedback we've been getting across the
board is it's a it's a conversation
starter people are people are looking at
it in their own way and it's it's
hopefully you know giving permission
permission right yeah for the
vulnerability yeah especially for men
okay on the way out let's ask a couple
of these questions you know we're
currently at the Women in Technology
International at the summit we're here
supporting brilliant women we love it
it's amazing feeling especially young
women we're trying to figure out how to
utilize opportunity for everybody in the
world to have access to achieving their
actualization so what why do you find
yourself here at the summit like why is
it important for you to be here well you
know it was kind of ironic how I ended
up here I just got back from the East
Coast and one of one of the other
presenters was here so he met up for we
met up for lunch and then had the
opportunity to interact with some of the
attendees meeting up with a couple of
them later
I absolutely support what goes on here
and I think it's very empowering to you
know the again trauma doesn't
discriminate right and there's there's
so much power in in bringing the
diversity and the different perspectives
to the table and how they can the
synergy of that how it can lift up an
organization lift up a culture right so
I think this is exactly the type of
venue that needs to continue and just
really appreciative to be here yeah boys
[Music]
hard to break stoicism and men yeah yeah
it's a reoccurring theme in in my life
I've started to find it actually very
helpful and beautiful to just you know
it's your upper cry sometimes be
vulnerable be radically authentic with
the way that I'm feeling and that's
that's that's been tremendously helpful
and I think the more that we kind of
take in a little bit of
energy and feminine spirit with just
being okay those feelings and emotions
and being willing to talk to there's an
a holding space to talk to others about
it and to not be so quick to just shut
people down for feeling that way I think
we're gonna really combine these
energies into like a crazy Mouse burst
world and I hope we get there and hope
things like okay here's thought I hope
things like artful general intelligence
that we figure out how to prosper
through that a timeline so what I guess
I'm a question that we typically ask is
like how do we prosper with the advent
of all these new exponential
technologies and the way they're
exacerbating wealth inequality and where
do you think that that's all going and
that's a difficult answer when we're
talking about the complexity involved in
emotion the the metaphysical aspects
that are involved you know the
reductionist models versus the
metaphysical models right there's value
in all of them all I was is it's it's
it's something to watch very closely in
the field of behavior else right and
everywhere right the thing that I would
say is is is we cannot on we cannot
underestimate the complexity of these
these deeper emotions right and we're
probably quite a ways away from being
able to tie that to any type of
algorithm right it's I listed it from a
human standpoint right the way I look at
this is is development developing a band
of emotional plasticity right so that we
can operate within the range of emotions
that we experience all of them have
their values right like we think guilt
might be bad but guilt also serves as a
correcting mechanism in our lives right
to learn from it's an indication that
makasian that we can improve from
constructive past the difference is when
do those emotions become toxic right
when they're great when do they become
self-destructive so here's the thing
if if I you know when you talk about
stoicism especially in men right not
being able to recognize or suppress
their emotions why is it important to do
that you know it's it's important
because if I cannot understand the
emotions that I'm experiencing right if
I can't even access them then those
emotions are in control of me mm-hmm I'm
not in control of it mm-hmm if I can't
understand how to how or why doors there
are intrusive thoughts racing through my
mind then my mind is in control of me
I'm not in control of it right so the
idea is that that by learning to operate
within the spectrum of what we
experience and an honor all of those
experiences right that's what gives us
real real wisdom real flexibility you
know over time so the more we understand
ourselves as human beings the the more
that's going to translate into the
technology side as well yeah right and I
you know I frankly I think although
fortunately we've made a lot of progress
in bringing conversations like this to
the forefront just in my last decade
right like and and I I think the more
that continues the more we learn about
ourselves the more the more powerful
human beings as a whole are gonna become
right
yeah and understanding emotion otherwise
will control us mm-hmm understanding the
feelings otherwise they'll control us
how about what's the most beautiful
thing in the world the relationships
that we share between one another you
know and there's there's varying forms
of love there's there's you know varying
degrees of connection right but if if
there is it's interesting for whatever
reason like there's there's some
synchronicity going on here
i-i've just got back from a wave of
talks a wave of podcasts and interviews
and I repeatedly got the question for
some reason like is there anything that
you fear mm-hmm and I've never got that
question before you know I guess I don't
know why people harass you but it's it's
what's your answer well I I was almost
stumped because I it was a really
complex thing to answer for some reason
what one I would say that I'd be
concerned if I didn't fear anything
right because but and the question is
what do I fear like how do i how do I
give a clear answer to that the only
thing that I've seen the primary thing
that would sadden me to to lose or the
thing that I would think about right it
is is like in a moment of death for
example will be the loss of love right
what what happens these are the
relationships that we have was our
significant others right and it's
interesting because I reached a point
where I literally have to remind myself
of what I experienced in that moment of
death to kind of reflect on that and and
and work through it myself right because
I have to remember it in the in that
final moment in the most beautiful
indescribable way all of that falls away
and we it truly feels like were part of
everything and nothing right that as as
as hard as this is to conceptualize and
understand it's it's almost like
anything that we can think of or
experience right now almost doesn't
matter right it's it's almost it's those
fears become almost irrelevant in that
in that final moment right and it as if
it's it's it's it's taken away satisfied
fulfilled all at the same time you know
and I I think that's the I guess maybe
in the end that's that's what faith is
in in some respects right is is being
able to being able to kind of have
comfort in believing that that's there
right
the relationships between us are the
most beautiful thing and then the love
being taken away is fear is fearful fear
fear of them yeah do you think we're
alone in the cosmos I doubt that that I
mean it's it's it's certainly as
possible but you know it's to me it's
almost impossible that there isn't some
other life-forms out there you know I
mean which is the massive scale of the
universe the cosmos that continues to
get bigger and bigger and bigger the
more we understand about it
I think it'd be just it's it's hard for
me to believe that there's nothing else
out there or no one or no thing I do you
think we're dissimulation who it's it's
it's not possible to negate it right
it's it's but they're in it it kind of
begs the question who's running a
simulation right so it's it's it's a
it's a possibility you know I think
that's a really interesting theory of
consciousness and I really do yeah
that's the reason why this shows name is
simulation right that's a very
interesting theory of consciousness it's
a very interesting mind expanding
thought experiment yeah yep toya round
at the variables think about it a little
bit right teach the kids about it soon
they have to say yeah give them that
fundamental understanding of how we got
here and also where are we going
right and who the [ __ ] are we right yeah
it's it's a wild day I think is we have
a responsibility to think through all of
these series right
because it's uh I mean there's the
simulation there is obviously very
powerful right so there's there's a lot
out there I mean yeah I guess in the end
right it's it's it's this we're all
writing it were in this journey right
we're in this process we're experiencing
it together and it's it's there's really
so much to still uncover yes and you
know if anyone thinks life's a dead end
I mean there's creativity all around us
right yeah actually you had that quote
it was creativity's the inverse of
trauma yeah that might be a good di I
really do i but I believe you know
trauma leaves us trapped in our past
constructs right that is like kind of a
core definition of trauma we respond in
the present moment based on our
experiences in the past and it prevents
us from kind of moving on so what's the
inverse of that creativity creativity
can dislodge us from the past innovation
can dislodge us from the past right and
this isn't just creativity or innovation
and things that you build into the world
this is also creativity innovation
within within good like growth growth
just growth mindset being able to be
with those feelings and that
vulnerability and those are kind of the
same kind of creativity really yeah yeah
absolutely
you know expanding your mind right
developing yourself music you know
creating music there are so many
different ways that you know we can
experience experience the world writing
and acquire new perspectives you know
that it's it's it's just sometimes we
need a nudge from other people to do it
because that that past trap of trauma
can be just very consuming right very
tight if the grip gets too tight then
hopelessness and suicide so we better do
a damn good job at helping out build a
stronger social fabric and anyway you
know there's a philosopher named Tim
Morton out of the UK and he actually
describes trauma as people being
caught in a state of executing past
algorithms ah yeah that's that's it very
interesting if you think about if we're
just droning through life if we're
executing the algorithm right where's
where is the innovation right where's
the creativity ah yeah yeah kid will
that will the algorithm stay in the past
right or will it get directed towards
the other future precisely mm-hmm so
it's an interesting it's an interesting
yeah every moment of thought is a choice
in a direction right but sometimes it's
important to go into the direction of
the trauma to be with to be with it and
fully give it the the full feeling of of
being there with those feelings and
being okay with them being vulnerable
with talking about them and and then I
where is the point when is the point
that it's actually appropriate once
you've been there to go forward and to
you know look back with a smile and mmm
figuring that out and how it ends up
being figured out has still yet to be
discovered and uncovered it's different
for every person but I think people like
you are helping us understand that
process and we thank you well thank you
we thank you for it so much Josh thank
you for coming out of the show it is a
pleasure to be here thank you for being
here with us into the fun conversation
you had a good time
oh yeah this is great awesome we learned
so much talking to you and left some
links in the bio to darker Souls as well
as the book beauty of a darker soul and
holy cow unpacking so much about about
trauma and transformation I mean this
was great this is definitely a very
solid conversation super-excited all the
[ __ ] all right everybody thanks for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it if
you guys had a good time shared the
content with other people get talking
about trauma and transformation get
talking about building stronger social
fabric giving that space for people the
beauty of a darker soul and then also do
give us a subscribe comment below we'd
love to feature your thoughts on social
you like video like go and create with
this content don't just consume go and
make something with it after you watch
it write about it
read about it make a video about it go
and start a company with it maybe go and
speak about it to other people get them
more willing to be vulnerable and join
us on patreon we need to continue doing
cool things like bringing our set out
here to Women in Technology
International and continuing to provide
you with this great content so thanks
everyone for tuning in and we'll talk to
you again soon
you